can you talk about love
a little bit sure so
you came out of the closet as being gay
when you were 25.
yeah it's a lot it's late very late very
late before that today's standards
during and after how has your
view on love evolve
interesting it's hard it's so hard to
say because like i would i
i'd like to make a very like disney fied
statement about like that you can't be
in love
uh secretively you should be honest love
should all be about honesty but that's
not true
right there's people that are in love
that are lying to everyone else
but they're deeply in love yeah um i
would love to say something like
honesty's of ingredient for love
you know but i don't know maybe honestly
with each other
but i mean i know i i think there's a
lot of people in the world that aren't
honest
my view on love is super important uh i
think that
it's we a lot of society in america is
all about
love we don't tend to focus on other
uh things in terms of like you know
uh friendship or sustainability
of that because i think that a lot i
know a lot of people in relationships
where it's like
i don't know they're not they are they
love each other but like
it's also a rock-solid couple because
they are
they're very compatible in many other
ways right so i think they're like
friends
they have right i see friendship and
love is the same thing right
there there's parts of it that are right
so it's like i look at it
as like there is there needs to be more
than just like that
like amazing like chemistry or physical
attraction
that is this chemical thing that happens
there should be like some underlying
i mean again that's from what i that's
what i've
observed as really long lasting
successful relationships well
is there something about coming out that
that was uh that you took away that you
remember as
yes profound and insightful and it was i
that i
it wasn't society it was me so there
were kids that were out in my high
school
that i waited years later to do it that
was no one's fault but my own
so i was taking a cowardly way out and a
lot of people so i could
blame society or like oh i lived in a
conservative area and i grew up
you should take responsibility for your
own decisions and if you're being
cowardly admit that you're being
cowardly
so that's what i took out of it is it
it's not society's fault
that you chose to be a coward society
will never be perfect
you have to be honest when you're ready
to be honest or however you want to be
honest
but it's not somebody too much now is
it's everyone else's fault
that you didn't take make a hard choice
or a hard decision so that's kind of
what i took out of it
so now in retrospect you see yourself as
were
being afraid do you right do you think
at the time
well i wanted people to like me which is
that was just the disease of
humanity right is that we want to be
liked and what happens is if you
want people to like you and love you
even you want uh people to feel
comfortable with you
and those were people like your family
friends
my family i would always you know could
always throw in the street but
my i'm kidding i mean but i am not yeah
uh
but my friends my circle of friends
which i were my family at the time when
you're a
senior when you're 10th 11th grade in
high school your fa your friends are
your fam
you know what i mean like that's your so
you don't want to do anything that puts
you on the outside of the circle
you